hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
orange comm and today I want to show you
how to give a subcu injection a subcu
injection also known as a subcutaneous
injection is an injection where that
goes into the fat of the skin it's
different than an intramuscular shot
which is given in a muscle so I'm going
to show you how that's done typically
heparin insulin lovenox those are given
in the fat of the skin today we're going
to give our mannequin Miss Smith a sub-q
injection of two units of regular
insulin and we're going to go in the
abdomen you can go in the back of the
arms you can go on the fat of the legs
or in the abdomen but I want to show you
how to do the abdomen first what you
want to do is you want to get your
medicine we've already drawn up two
units of insulin you want to get a
subcutaneous needle these should be in
your clean hole you'll want to get your
gloves do hand hygiene and get your
alcohol prep the end what you're going
to do is you're going to go to the
abdomen and you'll find the umbilical
area and you'll want to go two inches
away from the umbilical area and ask the
patient where's the last time they gave
you your shot because you don't want to
go in the same area she told me that
they went over here last time so this
time we're going to go on this side so
we're about two inches away from the
umbilical area what we're going to do is
we're going to clean the area for about
three to five seconds for the alcohol
prep in a nice circular motion keeping
it as clean as possible and this isn't a
sterile procedure you can use clean
gloves and we clean the area and then
we're going to get our syringe going to
take the cap off and you're sort of just
going to pinch the fat of the skin okay
and so just pinch that and you're going
to go in at a ninety degree angle like
you're throwing a dart so what we're
going to do is we're going to go
90 degrees no need to aspirate like how
you do with the IM injection just going
to give it take your needle out engage
the safety and put it in the sharps and
that is how you give a subcu injection
it's so easy and so simple take some
technique but after you get it down it's
easy so I hope you like this video if
you want to watch a video on how to
start an IV how to give an IM injection
I have all those so be sure to check
those out and thank you so much for
watching and be sure to visit my website
registered nurse Orion comm which is a
nursing resource for you and all the
nursing students out there thank you